-Our first guest tonight
is a talented comedian, actor,
and writer you know from his
work on "Saturday Night Live,"
"Tough Crowd,"
and "Train Wreck."
His new show "Small Talk"
is playing
at the Lucille Lortel Theatre
here in New York.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend
Colin Quinn, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hello!
-Hey!
Hey, I don't want to start off
with complaints,
but, you know...
[ Laughter ]
Maybe a nice cup,
a Seth Meyers cup?
-Oh, you want a cup?
-This is really cheese ball.
-I'm sorry.
Well, you had
a nice cup backstage.
Why'd you come out here --
-Now I look weird.
-Why do you want water
right away?
-Because I like to lubricate
my throat, you know, for the...
I'm a -- You know,
it's a professional thing.
In the theater.
-You're a theater guy?
-I'm a theater guy, yeah.
-Now, your show is about
small talk.
-Yes.
-What is some...
Was that small talk
we just had there?
What is some good small talk?
-No, that was complaints.
Complaining is not small talk.
-Okay.
-You didn't come in hot
like that.
-Okay.
-It's gotta be more positive.
-So, what's good opening
positive small talk?
-Like, well, you know,
the best...
One of the best ones,
of course today --
the weather, the rain.
Rain is like the, you know,
all-star small-talk stuff,
'cause it's always shocking,
even after all these years
on the planet.
Every time it rains, everybody's
like, "You believe this?"
[ Laughter ]
"What's going on?"
And then I can say,
"You look good."
And, you know, even if you
think I'm being fake --
But you do look good,
obviously you're working out,
and then, you know, you go,
"You're doing good,
you're looking good,
good for you."
And then you just kinda
put it on that person.
And you know, depends on
how you want to...
You try to read --
like, I try to read
if you want to complain,
you know, if I'm like, "I mean,
geez, what's going on?"
you know, or if you want
to be reassured, like,
"It'll work itself out."
You know, just kinda go.
-This is all very --
You're a natural.
You're a natural at this.
-Yes, I was born to do it.
-Now, I should say --
small talk, very different
from talk-show talk.
-Yes.
-Talk-show talk, I mean,
is a very unique skill.
-Talk-show talk, you have to,
like, come out with the story.
-Yeah.
-And so you can't small talk.
If you're in the elevator,
even if it's a big star,
and they can't just talk
to strangers and go,
"Oh, my God, wait till you
hear what David O. Russell,
on the set -- this is
actually very funny..."
[ Laughter ]
By the way, that's my most
modern reference.
David O. Russell. Sorry, folks.
-David O. Russell, very modern.
-A little behind the times.
-But this is very...
I was surprised to hear
that you like small talk.
I would have guessed,
if you'd asked,
that you were not a fan of it.
-I know that's how people think.
But what bothers me is people
that move to New York
and then go, "Oh, I moved here
so I don't have to be friendly."
It's like, um, I think you
meant to move to the woods.
Because this is a big city with
millions of people.
You have to be...
You're gonna have
interactions with people.
-And you get excited about --
Now, how short can small talk be
before it's...
I mean, I guess how long is it
when it's no longer small talk?
-Well, yeah, that's the thing,
is leaving.
You know what I mean?
-Yeah.
-Leaving the small talk
conversation.
Some people go too long.
You know, I'm talking
about the weather,
somebody in the elevator,
I'm like,
"Boy, weather's crazy."
They're like, "Yeah, yeah,
yesterday was...
Next week's supposed to be
even crazier."
You're like, "Yeah."
"Last week, Tuesday was..."
And then suddenly you're
pressing all the buttons.
You can't escape.
It's like social media.
-Yeah, but technology has
actually kind of helped
create an escape route for it.
-Yeah, the uncomfortable...
When you're done, you ever like
to unwind at Starbucks,
and you talk
and then you're like,
"Oh, God, there's nothing left
to say to this person."
And you sort of
half know them,
and you're just both staring
and you just feel terrible.
You bust out the phone.
You know what I mean?
-Yeah.
-In the old days,
you didn't have the phone.
You'd have to whistle, I guess.
I don't know
what they were doing.
That's gonna be talk shows.
In five years, this will be
every talk show.
What's up, Seth?
How you doing?
-Not much, how are you?
-Good, good.
Show's doing good.
-Yeah, and you got a new show
at the Lucille Lortel.
That's great.
-Yeah, yeah. Hold on.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, you think that we are
making a mistake as a society
because we're not teaching
small talk to our children.
-Yes, I feel like
we're the personality country.
That was our whole thing --
talk, free speech.
And yet kids get shoved
into school like,
"Study hard and
you'll be a success."
Is that really...
In this country, either
you can count really high
or you better have
a great personality.
[ Laughter ]
And yeah, so kids should be
walking in, you teach them like,
this is the big leagues.
You're going into society.
The rest of your life's gonna be
here, not with your family,
so you'd better
get it going, you know?
Walk in, and just --
just memorize,
rehearse a couple of phrases,
not surefire, but close.
You know, like, teach a kid
first day of preschool.
Walk in, "Is it me or is this
bus driver a little off?"
[ Laughter ]
You know, kids will be like,
"I like that kid."
You know, just have
a little story.
-Right, so right away,
the other kids are like --
-Be like, "Waving goodbye
to my Mom,
and you guys shut the doors
in my face.
You don't do that."
Work the crowd -- "You get it.
This kid gets it."
-So you think I should
teach my kids to say,
"You get it, this kid gets it"?
[ Laughter ]
-I think that's...
You teach them that,
and you teach them this.
If you want them to be
successful -- this.
When somebody's talking to you,
this works.
[ Light laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Absolutely tremendous, yes.
No matter what they say,
just say, "Yeah, good point."
And this --
people that go like this
make $40,000 a year more
than people that go like this.
-Just to nod along
while people are talking.
Nobody likes this.
-What if right now you were
talking to me
and I was going like this?
You'd be like, "I don't want him
back on the show."
You go, "Yeah, yeah, yeah!"
-Oh, I like this.
I like what you did there.
-Yes, yes!
-But now, you feel like...
This is tricky,
because you think
we should teach animals
small talk, but obviously...
-No, that's a misconception.
I'm just saying animals...
Animals, because
they can't small talk,
that's why they never
evolve past that level.
You know, 'cause it's always
a staring contest.
Even dogs, who you'd think would
know better by this point,
hanging out with us
for thousands of years.
They've still got that primal
thing
because they can't break...
It's like guys at a nightclub,
like young guys
when the music's loud
and they're just
staring at each other.
It always turns into a fight.
That's what dogs...
Even when your dogs are,
like, pleasant,
there's always that moment
you're like,
"Oh, this is gonna go off,"
you know?
-If dogs could small talk, what
sort of things do you think...
Like, what would you want a dog
to be able to say to you?
-Just, I don't know,
"I like your coat."
"You look good." I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
"Hey, did you see that rat?
Are you a terrier breed?
You know, well, believe
me, in my breed,
rats, we go after them."
And I go, "Didn't notice that."
[ Laughter ]
-Just breed details,
you'd want to hear explained.
-Yeah, I feel like they would be
able to be like,
"They think I'm this mixed
breed, but I'm actually this."
Like, "We keep it down
in our family, but we're..."
-I have a lot more
to ask you.
We'll be right back with more
from Colin Quinn, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]